la scène se passe à caracas il s'appelle
javier il a 11 ans dans ce magasin il ne
rêve pas devant les derniers jeux vidéo
à la mode
ils regardent avec envie l'étal du
boucher poissonnier
cela fait des mois nous dit il qu'il n'a
mangé ni viande ni poisson c'est trop
cher pourtant il faut manger du poisson
parce qu'il ya des protéines et du
calcium et c'est bon pour les os si je
pouvais manger de la sardine ça serait
bien parce que j'ai des problèmes de
reins mais on n'a pas les moyens d'en
acheter
en un an le prix du poisson a été
multiplié par mille avec la crise
l'inflation globale est hors de contrôle
13 mille pour cent en 2018 selon le fmi
mais les revenus n'augmentent pas aussi
vite alors au pays du pétrole
la majorité de la population afin comme
c'est écrit rageusement sur ce mur
direction l'un des quartiers les plus
défavorisés de caracas sur le flanc de
la montagne
nous voici chez soubaya escale aura elle
est infirmière vite avec ses soeurs sa
fille et ses petits enfants dans son
réfrigérateur presque vide
les provisions pour une semaine et pour
6 personnes du lait de la salade et des
bananes
on a toujours vécu modestement mais
quand même dans mon frigo j'avais de la
viande et du poulet avec des légumes
frais on ne peut plus manger trois fois
par jour sous ben ali à touchent le
salaire minimum 4 euros par mois on
compte ce kilo de riz ces deux euros ces
deux semaines de travail selon une étude
universitaire les vénézuéliens ont perdu
11 kg en moyenne en un an et les
premières victimes de la faillite
économique sont les enfants
c'est l'heure du repas dans cette
association manifestement cet
appétissant et cela se régale normale
avant de venir ici certains affamés trop
faible ne pouvais plus aller à l'école
cette petite fille de 7 mois souffre
réel de malnutrition à son arrivée elle
peser deux kilos de moins que la moyenne
je lui faisais juste un peu de souplesse
je viens d'acheter du lait c'était trop
cher 2 euros pour deux jours seulement
impossible
pas de statistiques officielles sur la
malnutrition mais l'association a fait
le tour des hôpitaux et les résultats
seraient alarmant selon nos informations
il y aurait six enfants qui meurent de
malnutrition chaque semaine ce sont des
chiffres auxquels le venezuela n'a
jamais été habitué
on croyait que c'était réservé aux pays
d'afrique cette génération qui meurt
c'est celle qui devra s'occuper du pays
dans dix ans avec une situation comme ça
notre pays ne peut plus avancer sur ce
parking
il y a fool des chômeurs mais aussi des
professeurs des infirmières qui
attendent avec impatience de récupérer
ce carton de nourriture subventionné par
le gouvernement
des pâtes du riz de l'huile aux
commandes
cette militante qui affiche le m du
président maduro sur son tee shirt pour
rappeler que c'est lui qui a mis en
place ce système il ya deux ans pour
rappeler que les bénéficiaires sont
redevables du gouvernement en place le
problème de la faim est l une des
questions centrales de la campagne
présidentielle et pour le gouvernement
les traditionnels distribution d'aidé
alimentaire aux plus défavorisés
constitue un moyen subtil d'obtenir des
voix